Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to let's
FFFFFF-
PHHHUCK!
MY NAME IS MAHRKIBLIER
MY NAME IS MAHRKIBLIER *MARK, NO NEED TO SHOUT!*
(BWAH)HA HO HO HA HO
HA HA HA HA HOHO
HA HOHO HA HO
HA HAHA HA  HO
*BWAH* HA HOHO HA HO
HA HA HO HO HAHO
HA HOHO HA HO
HA HAHA HA HO
*BWAH* HO HOHOHO HO
HA HAHA HOHO
HA HOHO HA HO
HA HAHA HA HO
*BWAH* HA HOHO HA HO
HAHA HA HO HOHO
HA HOHO HA HO
HA HAHA HA
UR`UR
(hey) ho ho HOO(hey)OOOO
(hey) OH OH OH (hey) OHOH OH (You feelin' it? I am!)
*BWAH *
(hey) oh oh OHHH(hey)
(hey) OH OH OH (hey) OHOH OHH
[HAHAHAHAHAHA](hey) oh oh OHHH(hey)HHH
[HAHAHAHAHAHA] (hey) OH OH OH (hey) OHOH OH
*BWAH* [HAHAHAHAHAHA] (hey) oh oh OHHH(hey)
[HAHAHAHAHAHA] ohoh oh OH OH (hey) WAWWWWOOO...
*BWAH* HA HOHO HA HO
HAHA HA HA HOHO
*BWAH* HA HOHO HAHO
HAHA HA HO
*BWAH* HA HOHO HA HO
HA HAHA HA HO
PENIS (PENIS) what mark?
POOPY (POOPY) ok?
POPPER (POPPER) idk whats happening
PANTS wut?
HEY
HA HOHO HA HO
HA HAHA HA HOHO
HA HAHA HA HO
*BWAH*
HA HOHO HA HO
HA HAHA HA HOHO
HA HAHA HA HU
UR`UR
[HAHAHAHAHAHA] (le dancing mark)
[HAHAHAHAHAHA]  (le dancing mark)
[HAHAHAHAHAHA]  (le end of dancing mark)